no problem for is I give you a little
bit of a background as i did i was
visiting in the netherlands in 1973 and
went to went to Dykstra's home at that
time and he was really excited about
something that he said was the greatest
scientific discovery of his life he'd
been working on a problem for for a long
time and he finally had the answer and
and he was bubbling over with enthusiasm
to tell me this this method of his where
he described a way of getting which is
essentially the thing in in in town for
probably the first of the end state
solution ought to problem for where he
was he wanted to to have when you have
distributed control lots of machine all
machines independent they still wanted
to do I be able to to be able to do
things like critical sections where
where the the machines would would know
that the other machines were not in a
bad state so that we that you could you
could machine could touch some global
resource even though it only had access
to its local name of the states of its
of its neighbors and the simplest case
of this was when he put all the machines
into a ring with with everybody having
two neighbors and he wondered whether or
not it would be possible to have have a
a mechanism so that even even when
errors are occurred or if you start out
with an arbitrary initial condition that
these machines will all come to a a
stable or a synchronized state when they
when they know that it's safe to to do
not to use it and well I was working on
quite other things so I didn't pay much
attention to what he said except I
remember his enthusiasm and that he
described the solution to me in it all
these parallel things always blew my
mind I could never really understand
very sequential person myself
then anyway he he published it the
following year after a fine after
finding some more improved solutions
apparently in the next two months after
after I saw him and and he published
without proof these these methods and
then there were a few other papers
afterwards but i'm i'm sorry i was sort
of surprised that that it didn't that i
didn't sort of see more waves being made
by this work you know like it would get
into our if it was really Dijkstra's
greatest discovery why didn't wide on
our course descriptions in in our
catalog say you know Dijkstra's
synchronizing method or something the
way we talk about other things by by
name that are that are famous so so so I
guess the the the idea didn't become
extremely well known for some reason
although judging from his his enthusiasm
at the time I was I was expecting it to
be mobile i was reminded of this last
fall when i was reading his sort of an
autobiographical account of of his
what's happened to him during the last
ten years or so fast i guess starting
mostly in the 70 this weekend he has
this book called selected writings in
computer science that that was published
a couple of years ago and like all of
his books it doesn't have an index and
so so i had to read the whole thing in
order to find out what he said about me
in it you know
well and it's really it's it's well it's
a fascinating book because it includes a
lot of trip reports where you go around
the world and say and and tell about the
awful things that happen lisa has very
refined tastes and is not afraid to say
when when when something disturbs him
and so it's aw it's a it's fun to read
those those gossipy sections to nuts
especially why I wanted to see what he
said about me so you know like he tell
us about the time you visited my house
and and he said he woke up at four
o'clock in the morning i hope it wasn't
because the bed was uncomfortable or
something like that but here anyway so
now in there yeah reprints this this
piece paper and some and the predecessor
paper that he had written about the time
that I first time when he had this
enthusiasm about him it reminded me of
this thing and and I thought okay let me
let me take a look at it because if it's
that interesting we ought to be able to
ask you maybe even a new question about
this about it and so I started out and
made up a problem for which I thought
was a new question and and I was to was
to say can we can we decrease the number
of states in Dijkstra's best solution
from three to two and I discussed this
with Ramsey as we were preparing for
this for you know the week before class
started and they later Ramsey comes back
to me and says no you can't do it with
with two states and meanwhile I had also
noticed it like when I thought of this
problem i had made a note to myself look
at science Citation Index before
assigning his problem in other words
there's do you do people know about
science citation index in library is
this way of referring to
to take every paper that refers to
another paper you can trace the
citations in backwards order so if you
want to say who who referred to
Dijkstra's paper in 1974 I can find out
everybody who's done so since then of
course the index is always a year behind
or something but but you can go back and
find out who's who referred to who
instead of going here at the forward
direction is easy but the backward
direction you need this science Citation
Index which is a an extremely important
research tool for finding out on what
else is known about a problem for
example if if you guys you know find a
paper of gimpel that that refers to a
heuristic you would be able to use
science citation index to find out if
anybody else's has analyzed that
heuristic or something like that for
example now and and there I saw lots of
references to to his paper may well
maybe it doesn't but they none of them
address the question of minimum state
except this except all of a sudden I I
had one more to check in and that and
that last one was actually a relevant to
the problem that I as I had originally
stated it a man named Maurice 20 did his
PhD thesis at Grenoble in 1981 but
trying to relating to this problem in
trance and showing that you needed at
least three states to have a to have all
the conditions that Dykstra won it and
so that that meant that the problem that
I had originally planned to give here
with us it was this is our two states of
solution was was already was already
solved and so in the middle of the night
I said okay let's generalize it so that
each machine can have a different number
of states and
the states that so your neighboring
machine might have you know how many
states he has but it might not be the
same as you then what can we say about
the minimum number of states of the
whole system which is the product of the
numbers of states in each individual
machine and that seems to be an
interesting problem that still hasn't
been solved and so so that's problem for
now trying to find out that the the
optimum on is in this sense number of
states now the reason that I like the I
mean like one thing I wanted to ask a
question it would that would lead us to
to get some intuition into this area of
parallel or parallel simultaneous
operation and so let's take a look at
the problem as it actually does anybody
have a copy of the exact problem
okay so now we've got states that we'd
switch so we've got a cyclic arrangement
of processors and so you've got p0 p1 GN
minus 1 and we're going to be interested
in enlarge limiting values as n is large
if we can't get exact values for all n
if we can get exact guys for all in that
would be nice but but limiting guys has
in his largest one of the ways that we
can simplify the problem if the exact
values there not to be too too
complicated and an hour well as their
ancient a ring but will actually
linearize it then just imagine wrap
around so we hope so we tweak these
right the state's down in a row and the
you say that that's a configuration and
now now we've got one thing that I made
that simplifies the problem a little bit
more than the real-life situation and if
we solve it and if I if I think it's
useful to to deal with a simplified
problem because if you can't solve the
simplified one you can't solve it more
complicated one probably but there's a
simplification to with respect to the
real situation in that I'm assuming that
that there's a there's a master clock
that governs all of these things so that
from state to state we have a certain
you know at time zero we might have this
configuration at time one we have
another configuration that falls from
but in practice the these machines might
each have their own clock and and one
might be reading the states of his
neighbors but before he actually absorbs
that the fact that what his neighbor's
state is that state might already have
changed because the clock rates are
different so I'm assuming a simplified
version of the thing but a lot of the
ideas will will generalize to the to the
more complicated case still it's not
the purpose of this problem let's not go
out of our way to make it too
complicated at first let's try to solve
a simple case where where we've got a
where we've got the same clock time so
what happens is that each of these at
each clock time work up these are going
to change to another configuration and
um let's see how does it work p j prime
is is a is a function depending on j of
the of the neighbors and the end the
state of the other machine so each
machine has a state and isn't it any
knows the states of its neighbors at
time T that time T plus 1 we have a
situation like this where each one goes
is some function of the preceding one
now the same at funny episodes your
transition yeah F sub J stays the same
yeah so f sub J depends only on Joey
down on the time yeah now the
we say that time actually has passed if
at least one of the piece it PJ Prime's
is different from pj if all if this is
just an identity transformation we just
ignored this as as saying that you know
time hasn't maybe the electronic clock
has ticked but the actual virtual clock
hasn't ticked so we also assume that
we're only interested in cases that at
least one of the least one of the piece
has changed single valued or FJ is
single valued yes so really this it's
later man did I say that I mean that
there was a case of fgf being multiple
value but I put that pipe it's a
function it's a it's a single valued in
this case you could generalize the con
tu tu non deterministic a case where
they were guards you know if you have to
two different ways to but I think it was
that stick with the deterministic case
or each one but so if it doesn't pay is
that the PO she doesn't change in single
valued and after one iteration it
doesn't change time to just stay there
stay you know just say that again you
know sticks if it sticks for one
transition oh I'm still stick forever
for some j and pj prime equals pj for
other kid ok this is for j and s and
this is for j in knowledge asst so some
of them will will move another phone
just saying it's not love I might choose
a subset of the okay so so so the idea
is that it's not that that you bet you
don't have to move if you can okay let's
see first of all what does it mean to
move there's if F if if if at that
particular values of these states if
ever of j r pj is different from pj then
we say that that processor j is able to
move but if giving but there but for
many of the state's FJ of PJ will be
equal to 2 PJ and anyway then we say
it's blocked ok so those presidents are
blocked if if they if they don't have to
have a state where we're in the
neighborhood so they're going to be
certain cases where we're allowed up to
to move but a lot of times f.jpg will be
just PJ now what the three actual rule
is that says if if there are K
processors northern 0 able to move then
we take any sub than any subset of the
moves can be made at the next time at
the next time so so so they don't have
to move so so suppose that we post
processor jay is in a situation where
where it can move that means that pj
month that dysfunction is not equal to
two pj well that case we still don't
have to we don't have to include it in
the set of processors that move so let's
take a look I suppose we can take an
example come so if you decide the next
time that it
Yeah right if you got it doesn't have
some look it doesn't have to move if it
doesn't want to anybody can pass so it's
so sorry yeah so I'll actually you have
your choices from you're not and the S
is depending on that depends on time
yeah so or let me just say that or pj
you got your choice and and at least one
of them does move if time passes okay
well now now the conditions that we we
want to make our that there is at least
one processor can move that there's no
we set up these functions in such a way
that that that no matter what there's a
way to move no matter what configuration
of no matter what configuration we have
so that we'll never get to a situation
that's that just dies and everybody's
blocked that's then there's another case
that selects the first condition the
second condition is that that that in so
called good configurations at most one
processor can move in other words since
there's at least one processor can move
always then the good configurations
exactly one processor can move so so
there will be also a definition of
configurations that are that are that
are good and and we're going to decide
you know have some criterion of goodness
but that that's an external thing on the
cockpit which is also saying that the
system is in a good situation the whole
whole system is in a synchronized state
if we have a good configuration so when
it's a synchronized state then the then
it then one processor is able to move
and
this will mean then that if that
processor is doing something to a global
resource it won't none of the other
processes will will will interfere with
it by trying to change that you know so
you could you could be setting our
global variable or something and nobody
and knowing that nobody else's is is
touching it at this moment because
you're the only one that's able to move
and then what then after you do move
then somebody else gets a chance to move
the third property is that each move
from a good configuration leads to
another good configuration and so you
can't get out of a good situation once
it's good it's always good unless some
some malfunction occurs where where the
system goes down or something like that
then and we have something we want to
get back into into good configurations
again and so that's problem property for
that says that no sequence of moves
takes a bad configuration into itself so
so you consider all the configurations
all the possible configurations p 0 to P
n minus 1 all possible combinations of
states there are good ones and the other
ones are called bad if you have a bad
one and then you move from the bad one
over a sequence of moves you'll never
get back to the original bad one again
this means that similarly you got to get
to a good one because if you if you know
there's only finitely many bad ones so
you're going to have to keep coming you
know going through until fun you get to
a good one once you get to a good one
then you stay good for that time on so
there will be some cycle good good ones
that goes on and that the cycle at the
end has the last property that I meant
that I'm that I have on here is says
that any cycle of moves which would then
be a cycle of good configurations it
includes a move by each processor means
that you can't have a psycho we're only
processors one and two get to move
and processes three and four are
starving and never get to move so so we
also have this effect that so the five
properties i can write them up on the
board sometime with that but that's i
want to introduce the problem today and
then and then i get into a discussion of
trying to 2 to 12 some more deeper
analysis some next week so first of all
let's just look at Dykstra stress
solution and let's be so here he had it
only depending on on the Left neighbor
and not on the right and all and in all
cases he has the same function except
there's that there's one distinguished
there's one distinguished machine in in
in the in the ring that's that has a
more complicated state so f 0 of of x y
and z is really independent of Z so is
that for and this is if um if x equals y
I'll let me write it this way y plus 1
if x equals line and y if x is unequal
on
so if your left neighbor has the same
state as you do in advance your state by
one otherwise stay in the same state
this is the this is your own state this
is your left neighbor its your right
name and the other guys it's always
equal to X this is for I greater than
zero so all the other only other
processors either if if they decide to
move at all they just copy the state of
their of their left neighbor okay now
let's take a look at what this what this
does we got by the way I've got to say
what y plus 1 means that's modulo M so
there's m states and and so this
subscript y plus one would go from M
minus 120 the states of you know go from
0 to n minus 1 and similarly in my
formula here when i said j minus 1 and j
plus 1 I was taken at modulo n modulo no
rapper wrapping around in uh so whenever
these things get out of range we just
saw those n processors here with this
with this function so take an example
where m by the way m is greater than or
equal n n is at least two otherwise we
have only one processor so so we have
let's consider the case where m is is oh
why not take em equals 4 & N equals 3
because because up you can take you now
equal but let's take the case that we
got different numbers so that we can see
that they're not exactly forced to be
equal so that's so we might start out
with a configuration and we have three
processors so
might start out with a configuration
that says what's a good random starting
point 3 13 14 except my states are 0 to
3 so forth snaps in 20 okay right for
pie okay now 310 okay now now who's able
to move in this case well is per
processor 0 able to move see if anybody
can follow Dmitri why not does the
previous processor yeah Primus or one is
able to move only when when x is equal
to Y that means that it's state is the
same as processor to processor 0 I'm so
processor 0 the this this this look this
the left hand guy is going to change
only one when it's equal to the one on
the right but the other two processors
can move or this one this one can change
to a three this yoga changed to a one so
one of the things that week that they
could do is both change for example they
could go like that or it could go to 330
or it could go to 311 those are the
three possible successors of this
configuration it must be a bad
configuration because in every good
configuration is supposed to be only one
our processor can move and this it's
only one processor can move it can have
only one success success it professional
okay now well we choose one of these
lines in the case 331 this second
processor can't move anymore because
snow if you know x equals y so it
doesn't do anything the third process
for the first process is a zeroth
processor on single note to call these
guys 00 the left the middle and right so
let the left processor still can't move
because it can only move one when it
stayed equals the one on the far right
the middle processor can't move so this
one has a forced successor 333 this case
is same the same deal 333 in this case
this the the mid the right guy can't
move and the middle guy can move to 331
which takes us into case that we that we
already have handled so in all souls so
pretty soon we're going to get down to
333 here now first the left-hand
processor can move and that goes to 0 33
now only the second processor can move
it's got to go 2003 I'll neither third
process it can move got to go to 0 0 0
then we go on 00 on 10 and so on think
you see that we're now in a cycle of
good configurations where the good
configurations are artists are defined
to be the ones that you get where you
start with
some some configuration of the form P P
P P and P plus 1 P plus 1 at most two
state values and they differ bike I'm
sorry p minus 1 most to state values and
they differ by by one in that direction
although these are the good
configurations in this in this situation
and the the condition that's hardest to
verify all these it seems to me is that
when you've got a solution of the
problem is that is the condition for
that no sequence of moves will take a
bad configuration into itself that is
any any studying configuration
whatsoever is bound to lead in a finite
number of moved into a good
configuration those aren't all the good
configurations over those are that we
could define those to be the good
configurations I believe yeah why do you
have well why would something to say
just before you have any number of peas
and and any number of anything else
queues or something why would that be
good the series of satisfied um you
could you could also you could also
define eventually can also define a
larger class of good configurations then
then the smallest possible clusters and
it's not a unique definition but this
but these are definitely necessary not
north it's a property the one so whether
the good configurations have saying that
if you never go from a non good into
into itself and so if we add to the good
configurations that just makes that
property easier to satisfy so so that so
you can always add more configurations
that one each move from a good leads to
another good and so this means that you
can only use predecessors of good
configurations and it's being good no
I'm all right and then um and then the
other characteristic is that exactly one
processor can move let's see what I have
a note here 600 there yeah I had a note
to myself about that same thing so if
you have for example a state like 331
you might call call that good even
though it's you even though it's not you
know in a cycle so so Dykstra in this
original paper had a condition that that
said that all the good work all the good
configurations must be obtainable from
all the other good configurations that
you could you know in sort of a cycle
including them all but that's not really
an important practical criterion it's
better to weaken it this way so we could
we could also allow something like 331
and call it good if we wanted to saying
that that there were just two values or
something like that because then we
could guarantee that only one processor
could move and we still would take good
into good but we also generalizing
Dijkstra's and that we might have two
cycles of good of good things as long as
long as every processor can move in each
cycle we don't have to be able to get
from one cycle into the other cycle in
practice that's that's the kind of thing
that's that's that's needed not that
there was actually getting from one from
any good configuration any other that he
had in his original paper isn't isn't
important time of it okay now let's try
two instead of two states instead of
four states and see what happens so in
between the two state case we might get
well we certainly have the same we have
a cycle of good configurations just just
as before so one one one will be forced
to go in 2011 which will be forced to go
in 2001 which will be forced to go in
2000 and that is forced to go into 100
110 and then up to there again the two
that are left out 010 and 101 now 010
what can we do from that this guy can
move took this can go to 110 or this guy
can go it can go 2000 or and go 2011
that's if you make single mood ring
excuse me that's all the singles hence
the single moves out a good point and
then we cut so there should be seven
moves off together because to all three
guys can move so we could also do the
first two moves that would be 100 we
could do the first well effect we can
take it into anything else except itself
right because all three of them can move
and there's only two states right so so
one of the things they can go into is
101 for example which is the other guy
and 101 can go back in 2010 and so there
we have a sample of a bad configuration
going into itself so it it doesn't work
out when M is is less than n if you if
you allow only one processor to move at
each step however it does work when M
equals n minus 1 you can Jenny if you if
you allow if you say that now the only
one I look at a configuration you say
which processors can move and and then
you die you say at least one can always
move but then you choose one and only
and only move one that can move then I
literally would be ok but you should
make the restrictions prostrate yes I'd
love by just looking at it say before it
it shouldn't that's right so so here so
there's no way for us to to I mean
unless somebody gets to get Cey gets a
signal saying now not only can you move
with nobody else's as has gotten the
signal yeah that's uh that would need an
extra kind of synchronization which
could solve the problem and yeah right
so so with that so that begs the whole
trouble of trying to
so yeah so the idea of allowing any
subset of the people to move to move is
really is really inherent in the packed
in the applications of this so although
it still makes a mathematical problem of
saying only one can move it's not that
it's not the right mathematical problem
for for distributed stability
consideration okay so so there was there
are seven successors of you know the
cake people can move you got to the K
minus 1 successes any subset of any non
empty subset of other ones that can move
doing it okay so that shows the the
original solution that bikes their head
and now it's interesting I don't want to
go through now a construction of a proof
that in general it works that is it take
you no no bad configuration will ever go
back into itself it's it's interesting
to work it out yourself and so I don't
want to take that pleasure away from you
everybody do it you know by yourself you
know in that in a quiet room the main
idea is probably that if you start out
something you have to think big think of
a million na processors and being in
arbitrary initial initial condition and
we want to eventually get to the point
where where there's that I don't there's
only two different state values there
and it's a amok you might try to also to
see if you could solve the problem with
a wit with the same function without it
without one being designated different
from the other and I think they're you
you find it that there's no way to do it
at least if if you let me see there's
something about there there's something
about that you need you needed to
designate one of the process is
different from me
other because otherwise you know let's
see something about prime numbers if
there is a if there's a like if it's not
a prime suppose you have a million
things in the ring then then I think any
this there's some argument that says
that that a cyclic shift of a config
other other sequence of moves will have
to always be a another valid sequence of
moves and this will show that you can't
solve all the conditions I forget that
augment but but in a general case truck
on first try to prove that in a finite
number of moves you always get to a good
configuration with Dijkstra's
construction and then once you've done
that try to find the worst case what's
the how finite is it I mean is it duh is
it n cubed the two to the N is it square
root of n log in 10 what's the what's
the longest path from a bad
configuration to a good one and you get
to define good ones either in this way
or you could extend them as rich
suggested to just p and q no two
different any configuration has two
different values but this is this this
is a i think a minimum set up of a good
of good values day that could be done ok
now the similarly then he has a
construction with three states only so
that you have you can have n processors
for any number of n and he but he has
only three states 0 1 and 2 and the
proof was left to the reader to show
that it always it always gets into a
good cycle in his three state case now
I've worked that out in the notes I
don't want to talk about that now I want
to consider I think the rest of today if
we can't prove that you that this it's
impossible to do a two
state solution to this with with
arbitrarily large number of processors
so want to want to examine the the to
the set the the case of try to define
set a state transition function that is
going to that that that has only two
states per processor this would be
really nice if it were possible so we're
going to try to define another
construction besides on Diceman and by
showing that a two-state solution can
exist this will help motivate why he
come up with a three state solution now
oh I erased that oh we we could probably
come up with a two-state solution with
it with only three processors so away so
I guess that would be as a useful
starting point so we have so let's
consider first of all me2 states and
three processors and see if it's
possible to solve the condition his
conditions there and not so I better
list the conditions I put on this part
the first condition was
at least one processor can move from any
configuration at most one processor can
move in a good configuration third good
always leads to good I don't know how to
capitalize it right over want to check
distinction then bad
never leads to itself in four in any in
any finite sequence of moves one or more
moves from a bad will never take back to
the stupid to itself and the last one is
any cycle of good moves any cycle of
moves includes a move by each processor
those are the five condition and we'd
like to find a set a function f now that
or different different F for each for
each processor perhaps that will that
will satisfy these conditions and each F
is a function of of three of all three
processes your left neighbor and you and
your right neighbor turned out to be
heli everything hi okay ideas decision
it's the great cookies a great code from
time so use it you know in other words
some some kind of a code that takes some
kind of a Hamiltonian path among all the
three states where everything changes or
work that it exactly one bit changes I
that's what a gray code is only one bit
changes when you when you go to a
successor so grey fret is named after
Frank gray who did this in the forties
ok so this is 000001 people know about
grey coats what you do is you you just
take the you take the numbers in binary
end and replace everything by the number
of odd bits to the right or something
like that it's a
now so 0 1 1 0 1 0 and then we
compliment that the the left bit and
then that one sits and we repeat the the
process so that's just 1 0 1 1 1 1 0 0 1
1 and we make the arrows go this way so
all the eight configurations are
declared to be good and there is exactly
one move defined in every situation so
we just let this chart define the
function namely SFO of the if you look
at the the thing from each local point
of view it knows the whole state of the
system because you know yourself and
your two neighbors and then certainly
since there's no bad ones it problem
force is obvious problem 5 is obvious
because there's only one cycle and
everything is clear ok well I was too
easy go to four processors
okay now in four processors you each one
only knows three of the bits of the
state each processor only knows it sets
on state and the states of the teenagers
so ideas you said this couldn't be done
did you know i did i said for for
sufficiently large n it could it
couldn't be done but but even though eat
even so you're trying to well I don't
know you can we can we can try and then
see if it face you can try something and
see if it fails and so so let's for
example suppose we start out in state 0
0 0 0 in in a sense this can be done
without loss of generality because we
could probably map everybody so every
processor could change its state if you
yeah renumber all the states and
transform the functions accordingly
right so we can we have a starting point
anyway now 4000 we can decide words what
it's going to go into but we thought we
can also decide it's good because
something summer's gonna be bill
starting out of it but so so suppose
it's suppose that there's a good state I
mean a good configuration there's got to
be one good configuration right if it
weren't 0000 then we could we could
renumber all everybody states where the
state's you know at the state will give
if they like to call it one we could
call it zero and just change the funk
that the neighbors function whether the
neighborhood was reading the thing is
the other way so there's a sort of
arbitrary naming that we can do so we
can say if that that 000 is a good
configuration you can also say 1000 is
your next
configuration okay why is that because
somebody has to be able to move in a
good configuration exactly one processor
is able to move and so it might as well
by cyclic symmetry in our ring it might
as well be the first one so you can take
this into this guy for example as uh as
a other thing so now what does this tell
us about the functions F of F bomb well
we got let me see how bitter I better
plan ahead here so 0000 goes into 1000
and now I've got four functions one for
each processor and f0 the first function
for the left processor f0 takes 000 into
one night could go to 11001001 excuse me
I i want to write down the idiom is the
partial information that i have about
the functions first come on up I want to
say what it's gone so so the assumption
first of all that f0 can be that that
would that this can go into this says
that the first processor can move but we
also assumed because it was good at the
second processor could not move so that
says that F 1 of 0 0 0 is 0 because
otherwise it could move and similarly
down these guys
okay so now in this in this next step in
this next situation then we're looking f
0 of 0 of 0 1 0 is involved f one of 100
is involved f 2 is still sitting at 0 0
0 and f 3 we're looking at 0 0 1 and so
we know that put that to processor 2
can't move so either processor 1 or
processor 3 or processor 0 yes one of
those other three can move
okay so now in this could in this next
step in this next situation and we're
looking at f0 out of LSU of 010 is
involved f1 of 100 is involved f2 is
still sitting it 000 and f3 we're
looking at 0 0 1 and so we know that
that to processor 2 can't move so either
processor one or processor 3 or
processor 0 oh yes one of those other
three can move this is 0 oh ok oh wait I
got to take turns here igloo hasn't who
hasn't spoken yet it took off Mike okay
well 0 can do because that would take
you back to where you came from that's
two shorter cycle 0 can't move because I
would take us back no word if if this
went back to 0 then we would be it
wouldn't be too interesting and it would
violate condition five but what
condition 5 would otherwise you know if
we didn't have conditioned five I think
that's the only thing that's violated by
the salt you don't want good ever
thought so so in fact 010 has to go into
11 all right so processor 0 can't move
process is between one and three knots
Oh what did you see it doesn't matter i
wonder that's not right i was 20 for
Roger to sadies why does it matter this
is an issue since then we haven't used
Allah so if you were in brillion
they probably rely only symmetric about
siblings for nothing and also about
reflections and so so our art our our
symmetry is not but now we've exhausted
this image we have eight symmetries of a
floor of arena for Ellen so that ways to
put the ring back on itself without
using exit but we can assume that it's
this one can move and this one can
that's it so that means that this guy is
going to go into one and this guy is
going to go in 20 so then he moves ok
now let's take a look at the next
situation in now we're sitting at 01 14
for the zeroth processor 4 processor 1
110 4 processor to we start now got a
new situation 100 processor 3 is 0 0 1 1
still so processor 3 is still blocked
and so at leat at most one of those you
know exactly one of those three it's
going to move now getting a funny game
they're going to can't be processor one
it can't be this with the processor zero
or positive one yeah this guy this guy
once you move you better not move twice
in a row because you let me just get
back to the same same loop okay so this
has to be fixed okay so so every time
you do move that's a condition that we
could you know we could wreak it out
impose on our function that says that if
you move then the corresponding thing
after the movie is a fixed point okay
that will speed up about some of our
other calculations so all right so so
now we got two choices let's look at the
let's look at the ones the first one so
suppose the first processor goes back to
zero here so then we get 0 100
because along too yeah let's see if this
see if we know what's going to happen
after 0 1 0 0 then we got a 0-0 let's
see who can move 32 again since I say
it's big videos two and three fat loss
is it right to we're assuming that too
can't move from here so it can't move
from here and three target is known it
can move from that and two if you would
be a zero world one from there you get
back to a previous state okay so so so
too would have to move because one can
move twice in a row so it would have to
move in ellicott expected to to a
previous stage is that bad to be in a
previous state this station he says
because the other guys haven't moved
here okay so therefore it's like
backtracking we had only one other
possibility or as Sherlock Holmes would
say after you've ruled out all the
things that are impossible the one left
no matter how improbable must be correct
or something else should we go so this
one is one and this one is one and of
course then we also know that after it
moved it has to it has to stay so that
takes us to 11 10 by inexorable logic
and let's see what's going on now we're
getting more and more things filled in
even though our symmetries are going
down so so this is one oh sorry 011 we
already got it it's 111
and I'm 1 1 0 1 0 1 okay now a
high-level observation strikes me yeah
okay about the center well we've used up
by symmetries but there's something else
the renaming argument can still be
applied i think in other words we could
still argue i think that that's dumb you
go very check me on this let me try to
sing say without mumbling too much for
jobs we could if we had a given our
initial configuration not as the 0 0 0 0
but as x0 x1 x2 x3 and and for arbitrary
x0 x1 x2 and x3 then our next state you
know then we would have used x0 well
this would have been x 3 x 0 x 1 here
and this would have been x instead of 0
0 0 here i would have had x0 x1 x2 i
would had different different names for
these guys here but still there would
have been it would have said that if i
go from start with x0 x1 x2 x3 i could
go through i could I could rule out the
case of first moving one guy the next
and then moving the first one again so
I'm I'm claiming that since we couldn't
yes this is a move of 0 1 and we show
that you couldn't move 0 and then 1 and
then 0 I'm saying that that that
argument could be generalized so you
couldn't move one and then two and then
one looks because I could renumber I
could rename all the states and here's
the same kind of argument on their
different things all this is up anyway I
we would soon find I believe that that
it can't be one moving again because 10
moved here one moved here to move to and
if
was again then we're going to be in a
similar situation as we had when we
finally rule out the 010 case so so I
bet you just has to be this way so 0 is
blocked because to just moved in and 0
doesn't even know number two three
canoes yep three can move after but not
you know but but at the moment at the
moment there's only one there's only one
Bible continue this and that's 43 to
move because if we because we know that
two can move twice in a row and are also
claiming that you can't have a
one-to-one for the same reason we
couldn't have a 010 so it's got to be
three and so that's where we are now
well if if we can't okay but now the
argument is pretty it's the same
business beginning to loop on itself
because we can't have two three to
either same reason we couldn't have 0 1
0 and 1 2 1 and so 232 couldn't be
followed by two three three or two I
mean two three can't be followed by
three or two so it has to be one or zero
can't be 1 because 1 is is on is but one
doesn't even know that three has moved
one's neighbors are as Iran too so the
only thing that can possibly happen here
is the 02 move gotcha 02 move and this
means then that one one one is kind of
take is going to go in 20 in it would go
0 1 1 1 and 0 well we're we see what's
going to happen and this is going to go
0 0 1 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 whoops
so want to move to a movement 3 i'll
move i didn't turn the corner festive ok
so now that's eight of them are covered
in this situation and this was sort of
forced on us except a little bit of
symmetry that we used in there now what
about the other eight there are sick
there are 16 configurations in all what
about the other eight I haven't started
I unfilled in these functions here but
let's see if we if well I gotta erase
this only two minutes to go so the ones
are missing for example 0011 it's
missing you stay well it's there sorry
0101 it's missing you know 101 is
missing and what do we know about it 101
has Nick so let's see does anybody once
everyone is this 20 display which one
lower right-hand corner there ok so
which guys do we know are blocked here 0
is blocked because two neighbors are one
and that's that's occurred before one is
is so there's no situation where that's
been surrounded by zeros is it so that
could move this Camille and but this one
is bluff return so so we could say go
from there too
00 01 which takes a spoon into the last
one has to change which is all right but
it doesn't help me to be able to change
you okay it's gotta be similar change so
we better do that with two is it locked
2 108 federal you say that this one but
this one was something here you know
does not okay alright so so then we can
move into that well we don't have time
to go through the whole details but I
believe you can take the other Asian
region into a psycho and those two
cycles between them do exhausted so that
for 4 processor who endures and on
tuesday i would like to see a proof that
with five you can't i claim that the
other eight will fit into a cycle of
good a good cycle and everybody will
move on that cycle too but if you're in
that taffy won't be a perfect is that
that still satisfies conditions 1 2 3 4
and 5 30p start of that state does
nothing is bad everything is good oh
there's always one moved from every
state from every configuration as long
as always one move but understand
everything is in two cycles so if you
start up one cycle you I standard cycle
throughout all history but Utah he's
good it we call this cycle should any
other cycle bad no i don't that's always
very good
comment oh I love them both oh very nice
i'm a very friendly guy so you can get
the idea that's right is this but this
this moment is you know all like
everybody in this situation okay so see
you on on Tuesday remember 14 days left
for problem for our art show was the
imaging going to be working